hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a really fun geometry problem
start out with a triangle where one
angle is equal to 20 degrees and another
angle is equal to 80 degrees
now draw a line segment such that this
length right here is equal to this side
length
the challenge is to solve for the
measure of this angle using only
elementary geometry you're not allowed
to use trigonometry or other methods
i thank barry and i also thank akshay
devare from india for emailing me this
problem can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so i admit this was a very challenging
problem and i was not able to figure out
the trick on my own
but i was able to find the solution
online and i'd like to present it
because it uses a clever trick so let's
get started by considering the big
triangle
we'll solve for the third angle
this will be equal to 180 minus 20 minus
80 which equals 80 degrees
now this triangle has two angles that
are equal to 80 degrees
so the sides opposite them will be equal
this will be an isosceles triangle
we'll put these sides in green to show
that they have equal length
now let's zoom out a little bit
and here's the clever trick
along the top side of the triangle
construct an equilateral triangle as
illustrated
so all of these side lengths have equal
length to the green side
since it's an equilateral triangle all
of the angles will be equal to 60
degrees
so this is 60 degrees
this other angle will be 60 degrees in
total so this will be 40 degrees and
here we have another 60 degree angle
since the very top angle is 80 degrees
we know that this will be 80 minus 60
which is 20 degrees
now let's connect these two points
and furthermore we'll focus on this
triangle
now two of the side lengths are equal to
each other because they both have the
same length as a green side
so this is an isosceles triangle with a
central angle of 40 degrees which means
its other two equal angles are 180 minus
40 which equals 140 divided by 2 which
is 70 degrees
so here we have a 70 degree angle and
the other angle is also equal to 70
degrees
so if we remove 60 degrees from it this
will be equal to 10 degrees
now let's go back to this diagram and we
want to solve for this angle over here
how can we do that
well here's the other insight
look at these two triangles
now they will be congruent to each other
by side angle side because both of these
triangles have a blue side then a 20
degree angle and then a green side
this means their obtuse angles will be
equal to each other so this angle here
will be equal to 80 degrees plus 70
degrees which is 150 degrees
finally we can solve for the angle that
we want to
this will be equal to 180 minus 150
which is 30 degrees and that's it
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video
these math videos which can be watched
for free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they have over a hundred million
views please subscribe for free to get
the news videos and you can email me a
puzzle or math topic presh mind
yourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
merchandise which is listed on teespring
you can get my books which are listed in
the video description and you can
support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support